Speaker 1: Let's go to Dean from
Dallas, Texas. Dean, welcome to
the program. What's on your mind today?
Speaker 3: Hey, David, can you hear me?
Speaker 1: I can.
Speaker 3: I was wondering, are you
familiar with South Korean politics at all?
Speaker 1: Only in passing.
Speaker 3: So South Korea has kind of had
a historical problem with their presidents.
They've sent Lee Myung bak for embezzlement and
bribery. He's gone to jail for a long time. Park
in here is a female president, and she's been to
jail for her abuse of power, bribery, coercion,
leaking government secrets. Even the former
President Moon, he's under investigation. He
could go to jail. My question is to why a
democratic country like South Korea has no
issues prosecuting and jailing former presidents
and politicians. Politicians, but the U.S. can't.
Do you think culture and tradition trump law?
Speaker 1: I do. I do. And you know, if you go
to my birth country of Argentina, you'll see
there is also a long tradition of corruption
and arguable criminality from presidents and
leaders. And the last one, the previous one seems
almost always to be under investigation. And the
dynamics within countries, I think sometimes maybe
the right term is that there are these over time
implicitly. It's not like people sit down and say,
here we jail former leaders, and then in another
country, people sit down and say, here we do not
jail former leaders. I believe that it's small
decisions over time that are a combination of
how the judicial system and court
system, the judiciary is set up,
how judges are chosen, cultural attitudes towards
misdeeds by elected officials. All these little
things together lead to some countries where it's
completely typical that you jail former leaders
and others where you don't. It also exists in
the U.S. at the state by state level, I mean,
look at New Jersey's history of prosecuting
former governors, which I mean, you could say,
well, they've had a lot more criminality among
former Jersey governors compared to another state.
But there also seems to be something there about
expectations. So I think it's all of these things.
Speaker 3: Okay. So you think like
the fear of public retribution
or violence impacts our justice system?
Speaker 1: That I don't know specifically.
It's possible. That's possible. But we'd really
have to ask more to understand people's attitudes.
But I think there is a cultural component
and there's also a sort of cumulative
component over time related to expectations.
Speaker 3: Okay. Well, thanks for taking my call.
Speaker 1: All right. Dean from Dallas,
thank you very, very much for the call.